I like taking the guns early like in
this crazy man's case that just took
place in Florida he had a lot of fires
they saw everything to go the court
would have take a long time so you could
do exactly what you're saying but take
the guns first go through due process
second you have to look at the age of 21
for certain types of weapons I mean some
people aren't gonna like that but you're
gonna have to look at that very
seriously well he looked at Pat Toomey
at one point and Pat Toomey who did the
bill with Manchin that's being proposed
and he's in chummy says well that's not
in our bill and the president says well
you know why because you're afraid of
the NRA
I was just stunning he also added that
he wanted to strengthen background
checks for gun buyers that's fine and
the problem is those policies have been
fiercely opposed by the NRA and other
advocates that he said he was standing
with on most issues a little bit
confusing and joining us now to discuss
this and a lot more jeff sessions
fallout is republican congressman ron
DeSantis and fox news senior political
analyst britt hume it is so great to
have both of you on the show Britt I
don't think you've been on on the
Ingraham angle before unless I'm really
losing my mind so thank you for joining
us we appreciate it I have it's not my
first time Laura I've been on your show
before okay that's right you were here
in studio with me thank you very much
Britt what about this Trump bipartisan
meeting today had the cameras pulled in
it was interesting he was sitting next
to Dianne Feinstein and you had Manchin
and Toomey there who had come up with
interesting legislation and then the
President kind of hits to me and says
well you're afraid of the NRA and I I
don't think Jimmy
seems to be afraid of the NRA on most
any issue that I know of I think that's
right and that to me had I don't
remember the exact words but Tim he had
a pretty good comeback so you know it'll
go in the books as president attacking
Republican senator but but I think it
was something the world will little note
nor long remember Ron congressman De
Santis
on this issue of this meeting today at
the White House I mean Twitter blew up
social media blew up because people
watching this did
know what the president was advocating
or saying and at one point Dianne
Feinstein said well what are we gonna do
about these weapons of war and he
basically seemed to say well we should
look at that too as in you know either
I may be an all-out ban it was just very
difficult to follow but she seemed to be
kind of rubbing her hands together I'm
saying oh goody now maybe this was all
just a show but and I know you know you
and I are big fans of the president but
this was a wild thing I mean it was it
was not cool for a lot of people who
believe in the Second Amendment when I
think the overall debate not just with
that meeting but but since this has
happened you have an instance in which
the authorities had dozens of calls and
visits to this shooters home people in
the school knew that this was somebody
who had serious problems obviously he
got kicked out of the school so you had
all these red flags and of course the
FBI was given a specific tip that he was
going to commit a school shooting and
yet they were they fell down on the job
that is the number one issue that comes
out of this and then I think there are
obvious things that we should be doing
on a state and local level to harden the
schools to provide more visible security
yeah and to deal with the mental health
issues I mean all that stuff can be
dealt with I think you could get really
good even bipartisan support I think
when you start going into waters that
Dianne Feinstein wants to go down that
is just not gonna that dogs not going to
hunt in the Congress yeah take the guns
and then do go to the court later I
wasn't following any of that but um we
have to get to the bad blood between
Jeff Sessions the Attorney General and
Donald Trump this continues and I know
Brit you tweeted about it today and so
did the president the president started
by saying why is AG Jeff Sessions asking
Inspector General to investigate
potentially massive Pfizer abuse will
take forever has no prosecutorial power
and already late with reports on Comey
isn't the IG and Obama guy why not use
Justice Department lawyers disgraceful
and Brett you said this is Trump at his
worst he's asking the DOJ to investigate
itself the Inspector General has his own
staff of lawyers investigators etc Brett
let's go to you first on this what is
what's Happ
putting here with this continued
frustration the president obviously has
with the Attorney General is this wise
Laura I think it's fairly simple I think
the president's conception of what an
Attorney General is supposed to be is to
be his political protector his political
and legal protector and as you and I
both know there are that is absolutely
not what the Attorney General is
supposed to do he's certainly supposed
to advise the President on legal and
perhaps in some cases ethical matters
but he is not supposed to run the
Justice Department as they use the
Justice Department to run interference
politically or legal for the president
and the president has been disappointed
from the jump with sessions because he
thought sessions over their justice
would be helping him out and dealing
with with the Russian matter and so on
and and sessions quite properly in my
view recused himself and this in this
instance quite properly turned to the
Inspector General of the department to
investigate alleged misconduct by the
department rather than having Justice
Department lawyers investigate the
Justice Department so I and I think the
president is clearly off-base here and I
think the nation has been well served by
Jeff Sessions and we all should hope
that the sessions will stay on the job
job regardless of this hazing by the
president congressman De Santis you also
tweeted on this matter and you you seem
to disagree on the best way to pursue
these FISA abuses well you're right
Laura the Inspector General I mean he's
a fine guy but he doesn't have any
prosecutorial power he can't hold anyone
accountable he'll take a year and a half
to write a report and offer
recommendations and there's a time and a
place for that but from what we've seen
over the last six or seven months just
the scores of people who've been demoted
or have to leave these agencies a bunch
of different potential offenses ranging
from false statements to disclosure of
classified information you need a
special counsel who can actually pursue
those matters somebody from outside the
Justice Department who's not afraid to
upend the applecart that's what we need
in this situation the IG just not going
to cut it when we look at Laura I was
just going to say if you're looking for
a quick investigation that won't take
very long as the congressman suggests he
would like to see the last thing on
earth you
another special counsel they famously
take forever they build up huge staffs
and they and they run far far afield
from their original purpose so I've had
constitutional bets about special
counsels I think regardless of that
they're a bad idea anyway and that the
last thing on earth we need is another
one of those other than Jared Kushner
and Ivanka Trump the only other person
that has been with President Trump by
his side in campaign or governing mode
has been hope Hicks and today was
announced that she's going to be leaving
the White House in the coming weeks how
big of a story is this Brit and will
that further perhaps destabilize the the
situation in the in the West Wing well I
think she's a loss to the president
because he trusted her and by all
reports she was very able wise as John
Kelly said beyond her years and was an
effective adviser to him and I suspect
steered him away from his own impulses
sometimes and and helped to showcase
what he did well so I think she's a loss
I don't think that it is that that her
departure is any kind of a scandal or
reflects badly on her I suspect she'd
had enough two years in that job at her
age is a pretty long long tour of duty
and I suspect that the opportunities
awaiting for her on the outside are
extraordinary and I wouldn't I don't
blame her it offered for seeking to take
to take someone up on one in congressman
De Santis and I'd heard some time ago
that she wanted to you know move on to
something else and you know other
networks are saying oh this is because
she had nine hours of testimony at house
Intel and and it was grueling and the
White Lies come in and they're trying to
tie this to the recent facts but I think
she was kind of you know gearing down
months ago but she stayed on because she
wanted to help the president your
thoughts very quickly yeah I mean those
are shift leaks about her testimony take
that for what it's worth she's been with
the president from the first day of the
campaign so she's been at this a long
time and it's not an easy easy jump on
both the campaign or the White House so
she was very respected and I think she
did a good job for president Trump all
right thank you both